it was 2004 and I was really just not
satisfied with with what I was reading
about the war and in particular about
the soldiers I felt that you know in
every in every paper there would be a
list of the soldiers who died which is -
their names the town they were from and
their age and sometimes there would be a
photograph and I felt very disconnected
from what was happening and from the
people who were serving and when I did
find out any information about them or
who they were why they joined it was
once they had been killed so I really
didn't know what I wanted to do at first
and but I I started getting
subscriptions to all sorts of magazines
and newspapers one of which was the army
Times and I was reading that for a few
months I think until I read an article
about Sargent use a and he had just won
the army time soldier of the Year award
for in part for being one of the most
successful recruiters in the United
States and there was a picture of him
you know leading basic like running with
a group of high school students and who
were his new recruits and he's and they
were so young and I thought wow I I want
to know why he's so successful who these
kids are before they joined before they
become soldiers while they're still in
high school and so I gave him a call he
got on the phone I told him that I was
interested in doing a documentary film
we spoke for a few minutes he agreed and
and then I said that's great and you
know we hung up and then about 10
seconds later the phone rang again and
he said well you know this is gonna have
to actually go through an army chain of
commands and I said no I figured that
and then a process began really for me
to get access and get a
from the Army it actually was remarkably
I don't want to say easy but
uncomplicated in the sense that they
just asked me to write a letter I did I
wrote a very short letter just
explaining what I wanted to do that I
wanted to follow Sargent use a and a few
of his recruits they did a background
check on me which I learned later after
people you know people who called me and
told me that they receive phone calls
from the Army and and that was it
and then I signed the contract with them
which I have to say was one of the most
film-maker friendly contracts I've ever
received and it really gave us an
enormous amount of flexibility and
control and really became it ultimately
became I think based it was based on my
relationship more than anything because
the army gave me the approval but at any
point any of the soldiers or the
recruiters could have said no we don't
want to do this anymore and but I think
I built a good relationship with them
and then also when I was at basic
training again it was at the discretion
of the drill sergeants and the public
affairs people there - at the different
bases to decide you know how long we
would stay what we would do and I really
you know he had a number of recruit when
I arrived there are a few recruits were
already shipping off - to basic training
and so they were there were a number of
kids and they were in the group that was
would be there for another year before
they they shipped so that was one reason
it really just happened I was looking I
you know they all there wasn't they all
had different reasons for joining and to
me that was interesting you know and and
they their backgrounds are all varied
and and so it just really fell into
place that way and I was
I found them all very compelling opens
things up because you really you know I
mean as well specifically to this film I
mean that they're at such a specific
point in their life who can't remember
being 17 you know and college seemed so
distant and leaving home and and kind of
the vulnerability and fear and an
excitement of that age and and you know
everything is in front of you and I
think that was what was interesting I
think it was you know to be with the
soul to be with them before they
actually went through basic training and
be went from civilian to soldiers and
made that transition it was I wanted to
be with them at that at the point in
their life before that so we can know
who they were before and why they made
those decisions now it was it was
incredible incredible I think that was
it was really unbelievable on so many
different levels but one you know it is
this incredibly stimulating experience
which I didn't really anticipate but you
know took it would take me like a week
to get over a week to be there because
you're just so charged after after being
there but it's uh it was you know it's
the first few weeks of boot camp are the
kids go through a tremendous amount it's
really that that transition from
civilian to soldier where it's the the
total control period where they're they
can't do anything they can't read
anything and it's that the very
stereotypical scene of the sergeants
yelling at you and and and being treated
and humanely
and that slowly changes they have this I
think they have the red and blue and
then white phase of bootcamp which they
go through and the red is a really
intense one but boot camp was you know
what they go through and whether it's
it's the different training it seems so
Justin now my god different trainings
for the infantry training is very
different than than just combat support
and so Fort Benning in Fort Jackson all
have you know are very very different
and and what the training is very
different but it was a very intense
experience and and seeing what they went
through was incredible no I think I
think that you know something that many
of them said afterwards is I don't think
they it's some do and others you know
for some it was it was not as a
difficult experiences for others and
them for others it's a it's a very
difficult experience and and I I don't
think you can really understand what
boot camp is like and until you actually
go through it so so no I I think you
know one thing the one here after said
in interviews that you know he I think
Matt and Matt says it's an interview
that he didn't know you know that he
just kind of he just went and did it and
he didn't know what he was going to
experience I think that it's difficult
at 17 and 18 to really understand as
Matt as Bobby's father says to
understand what war is to understand
what you're getting yourself into and we
have these ideas that are based on
movies and based on things that are just
very different than the reality